super manga I could you saw matter
you're gonna go to war the only thing I
do need a superhero
Cena guest earth
stay down but wanted it you'd be dead
already sorry learned what it means to
be a man
vadoma do you super
hey youtubers it's vacation Charlie so
we're going to be talking a little bit
about some of the Batman V Superman
stuff that's been going on they posted
some new pictures of the Batcave Ben
Affleck was talking about justice league
so let's go so the big deal of courses
they release a little bit of new footage
but we get to see the inside of the
Batcave like a much better look inside
ben affleck's Batcave what they're
really using him as is the anchor point
in this world of super being so you know
you have people like sod and the man of
steel movie you have wonder woman who
they're just getting to know Batman is
the human that ground this that you have
like a world of gods you have to have
Batman you could argue is kind of a god
in his own right depending on which
comic book you're reading now the
interesting thing about this is that
Batman's kind of let Wayne Manor fall
into ruin maybe that happened after the
Joker killed Robin and a lot of people
are wondering which Robin it's going to
be is going to be Jason Todd is it going
to be Dick Grayson I think it more
likely that they would actually stick as
close to the comics as possible even
though Batman V Superman isn't based on
a comic you guys let me know in the
comments like what do you think about
this version of the Batcave compared to
christian bale's Batcave which is way
more primitive and he actually he even
moved it to the construction site so the
one who used most of the time was
actually much closer to the city this is
taking it back to the beginning bat cave
underneath Wayne Manor as it should be I
actually did a Batcave video about the
history of the Batcave so I'll opposed
to link in the description but they
changed it a ton of times in the comics
and Wayne Manor itself didn't even
become a thing till much later after
Batman debuted originally he didn't even
have a mansion but most of what's being
said about the film leads me to believe
that Batman is going to be the leader of
the Justice League I mean it's a holy
trinity so they're all kind of in
partnership but you have to have
somebody who's organizing everything and
that's really Batman skills Batman is a
little more stationary until they get
use of boom tubes that would be awesome
now we're talking full-on Watchtower
boom to travel and if you remember boom
tube is the primary transport for cyborg
they're gonna get cyborg in this movie I
mean like in a small way maybe not
full-blown justice league level cyborg
but I'm hoping that he's kind of born
out of this desire to match the level of
batman superman and lex luthor like Lex
Luthor is creating this doomsday so
naturally the military or some other
force is going to try and create their
own weapon too but it really depends on
what they go with for cyborgs origin
story they could go STAR Labs they could
they could do it like the cartoons they
can do like the animated series there's
another big question for you guys if
star
Labs is like a huge deal on the flash TV
show do you want STAR Labs in Batman V
Superman to be the group that creates
cyborg or do you want him to come from
somewhere else we're not really there
yet and the movie version of the flash
is going to be in Batman V Superman in a
really small way but it's going to get
really confusing when we get to the
Flash movie but will be in like flash
season 5 or 6 by the time that happens
and as much of a bummer as it is that
Grant Gustin isn't going to get to be
Barry Allen in the movies it's really
just a time thing basically they just
don't have the time to go on a six-month
shoot to do it like a really big movie
and shoot the TV series so if it's more
out of necessity that Grant Gustin isn't
going to be in the movies it's the same
deal for Stephen Amell being green arrow
in the movies but we're not even close
to justice league yet so don't worry
they could always change their mind all
it takes is for one executive to go hey
you know what let's have some cameos
from the TV actors and I'm not really
going to hold my breath and we have
legends of tomorrow which is kind of
like TV justice league so we're kind of
already there with the TV shows but
there is actually a new legends of
tomorrow trailer they're posting all
kinds of footage so I'll try to do a
video for that before I fly back to los
angeles this is going to be like my last
day of vacation so I'm going to try and
post a video before I take off so
they're probably at least like one more
video tomorrow before I make it home and
there is a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway so all I have to do
to end of that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video lots more
Marvel stuff to talk about so I'm going
to move over to Marvel tomorrow to after
my legends of tomorrow video a whole
bunch of daredevil whole bunch of
punisher stuff I'll put some links for
that in the description too i've already
done a whole bunch of punisher videos so
why you guys wait for everything you can
click here for all my Batman V Superman
trailer videos there's been a bunch of
footage recently and you can click here
for all my punisher daredevil videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five and I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you